perdre d'excellentes affaires une
campagne commerciale exceptionnelle se
déroulent actuellement dans la capitale
britannique et andré célarié le
correspondant permanent de tf1 à londres
nous donne des précisions à ce sujet les
anglais sont déconcertants ils nous font
des misères dans le marché commun et
pourtant pendant ce week-end il offre
aux français un cadeau vraiment touchant
50% de réduction sur tous les achats sur
la notion de carte d'identité
la nouvelle s'est répandue comme une
traînée de poudre les agences de presse
la télévision il fallait s'y attendre
beaucoup proteste pourquoi pas nous
disent les anglais pourquoi a dit la
presse alors que la vie est dure ici
faire ce cadeau royal aux français qui
envahissent des journaux magasin
longueur d'année les français évidemment
sont ravis de l'aubaine
ils ont été enchantés de la surprise qui
leur a été fait
ça vaut quand même le coup si fifty
après tout c'était une manière comme une
autre de remercier les français de leur
fidélité de clients et à l'aube du
printemps c'est une manière très habile
très efficace d'attirer la clientèle
on en prend deux ou trois mêmes mais
même plus pendant 3 ou 4 à ce prix là
ils sont allons le règlement c'est le
règlement
la carte d'identité est exigée au
paiement et personne ne passe au travers
ce week-end exceptionnel a beaucoup de
succès et les français viennent en masse
à londres vous le comprenez bien les
anglais sont assez agacé vous l'avez vu
d'autant qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
déconcertés parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le sprint fool's day c'est à dire le
jour où les angles est
traditionnellement se font des blagues
les uns aux autres mais il fait très
beau à londres aujourd'hui 1er avril le
baron empain accompagné de son avocat
maître robert badinter s'est rendu
aujourd'hui